je suis toujours ce qui dope suisse et
la stigmatisation pascal joly peut
consommer seule sa fille sarah jane est
morte seule d'une surdose en 2019
isabelle fortier est convaincu que si
davantage de ressources avait aidé à sa
disposition les choses auraient pu être
différentes
montrant qu en considération la
l'importance de cette crise sur les
impacts salle sur des milliers de
familles canadiennes la santé publique
de montréal propose de décriminaliser la
possession simple de drogues dures comme
le fera la colombie-britannique dès l'an
prochain puis on a tout avantage à aller
dans ce sens parce qu'on le voit la
judiciarisation pour les consommateurs
or des effets importants pour eux en
termes d'accès aux services de
stigmatisation un outil à ajouter à
l'arsenal de lutte selon la docteure
mylène drouin pour éviter que la
situation des surdoses ne s'aggrave
montréal on le voit on a plus de
surdoses la crise n'est pas moins
importante ici toute proportion gardée
des organismes de prévention comme
cactus montréal constate aussi l'urgence
d'agir mais déplore l'inaction du
gouvernement provincial et ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on a nécessairement besoin
d'eux pour chacune de nos étapes en 2021
le conseil municipal de montréal a
demandé à ottawa d'aller de l'avant avec
la décriminalisation de possession
simple de drogue toronto a fait de même
mais le gouvernement fédéral n'a pas
d'échéancier pour le moment mais on est
ouvert parler
aux autres maires et mairesses et
communistes et provinces c'est frustrant
pour moi c'est vraiment ce constat de
d'avoir à se bâtir il ya on a des
solutions faciles à ce problème là mais
nouveau gouvernement nous leaders nous
disons que pour faire ça on peut pas
faire comme j'ai des proches d'éprouver
isabelle fortier d'avis qu'il faut agir
maintenant attendre la fin du projet
pilote en colombie britannique où
mènerait et 1026
si tu me permettrait au canada montréal